this is the third video in a series
about tackling the long essay question
on the AP u.s. History exam now in the
last video we were kind of weighing the
evidence about the New Deal considering
the ways in which the government the
economy and race class and gender may
have been either conservative during the
New Deal or radical and we came up with
some good evidence to support either
side and now it's up to me to choose
which way I'm going to go so I think I'm
actually going to choose the
conservative side here because I think
it's just a tiny bit more convincing and
if you're wondering why I think it's a
tiny bit more convincing I think the
part about Eleanor Roosevelt being an
advocate for race and Frances Perkins
being visible woman in a government
cabinet they to me don't seem like maybe
substantive changes they seem maybe like
they're a little bit more like
figureheads like things went well for
this one person or maybe just a tiny
group of people but in the grand scheme
of things it wasn't that big of a change
anyway you may feel different from me
you may decide that you would have
written an article about how radical the
New Deal was but I'm going to do an
example of a conservative argument about
the New Deal now our task here is to
take these themes that we've noticed and
the evidence that we have assembled
about these themes and turn it into a
five paragraph essay and that essay is
going to include an introduction with a
thesis statement
and a paragraph that explores one of
these themes and I think I might start
with the government theme a paragraph
that explores another one I think I'll
go with the economic theme and because
we're talking about economics here I
actually think we're going to roll class
into that one because it's about people
who are rich in people who are poor and
lastly I want to talk about the effect
on women and minorities so that's our
last theme and then we'll finish it all
up with a conclusion where we talk about
how right we were all right are you
ready for this so let's start with our
thesis statement so we've decided that
we think that the New Deal was
ultimately conservative so we could
start our introduction by saying
although the New Deal seems really
radical because it brought on a new
relationship between the federal
government and the economy and there
were so many new programs in fact it was
actually essentially conservative and it
was conservative because it did not
really change the essence of American
government the American economy or the
lives of ordinary Americans including
women and minorities all right I think
that's pretty good so let's move into
our first paragraph about the government
now with our thesis statement here we've
kind of set up a pattern for ourselves
to say the things that seem radical but
really are conservative and we're going
to do that in each of these paragraphs
so we can say what seems radical
specific examples of things that might
seem radical and it's in giving these
specific examples where you're going to
really wow the reader by showing the
breadth of your knowledge so it might
seem radical that there's a whole new
government bureaucracy around the
economy it might even seem radical that
there are women in cabinet positions
it might even seem radical that FDR had
this kind of first 100 days thing where
he said I'm going to achieve so much in
my first 100 days I'm going to hit the
ground running so that seems like a very
different form of government than what
you might have had in the 1920s in fact
you can even say that FDR is such a
active president right I mean he is
bringing a force of personality and also
governing ability to this role that
really hadn't been established that much
except for you know a few people say
Lincoln or Teddy Roosevelt so it does
seem like he's changing the office of
President quite a bit but in fact it's
really conservative because they're not
throwing the baby out with the bathwater
right they're saying that essentially
the democratic system works and you can
even compare the American government
with government's in other parts of the
world right now I mean think about
Germany where this economic depression
leads to the rise of Hitler so the
United States could conceivably have
become a fascist government in this time
period but they did not alright let's
talk about economics and the class
system in the United States so first
let's think about things that might seem
radical well it's radical that the
government puts together all of these
new economic initiatives like Social
Security or the Federal Deposit
Insurance Corporation the FDIC which are
new regulations about the banking and
economic system that are kind of
designed to make sure that ordinary
people don't lose everything if the
banking system crashes or maybe if
they're in old age and lose their job
and there's also a new sense that being
wealthy is not something that's
necessarily deserved right that there's
an element of chance that goes into your
economic status so I think it really
tears down a long-standing stereotype in
the United States that the wealthy
deserve to be wealthy
and the poor deserve to be poor that was
this a very popular notion in the Gilded
Age and instead says you know sometimes
bad things happen to good people it's
not everyone's fault if there's a
depression because we couldn't have
stopped it now we want to talk about how
it was really conservative and what
we're saying here is that the capitalist
system itself didn't fall apart you know
if you compare the New Deal to a true
revolution like for example the French
Revolution or the Russian Revolution and
these are examples where the poor rose
up against the rich and we're cutting
people's heads off and taking their land
then the New Deal seems very
conservative in fact what most of these
New Deal programs are trying to do is
not to demolish capitalism but to fix
capitalism so they accept the basic
premise that capitalism is good and that
certainly wasn't the case in many other
countries in the time period okay last
paragraph so again we're looking at
things that seem like they might be
radical and you could say it seems like
Frances Perkins and Eleanor Roosevelt
are women that have established a real
presence in the government and you could
say that New Deal programs did employ
many African Americans and at the
national level we're not intended to be
discriminatory but you could say at the
local level administrators are often
preventing African Americans and other
minorities from getting jobs and you
could also say that a lot of the New
Deal programs are really definitely
intended for men and you could for
example say the Civilian Conservation
Corps was a program only for young men
so women are often booted out of these
jobs or they're not even actually
eligible for them in the first place so
even though the New Deal is supposed to
be this great economic turnaround in the
United States it really doesn't change
the status of women and minorities much
at
all okay time to conclude so I think we
can pretty much just sum up what we've
said here that there are a lot of things
that look really radical about the New
Deal but in the end it doesn't actually
change that much about the basic
assumptions and basic structure of the
American society and economy and you
might even mention that it's not going
to be for another 20 or 30 years that
things like this change for women and
minorities and even during the 1940s
things kind of go back to the status quo
before the Great Depression right it's
this moment during the New Deal
where there are a lot of government
experiments about how to reorganize
American society and reorganize the
American economy but by 1940 things kind
of go back to the way that they had been
there are only a few things that still
remain with us from the New Deal and I
think those things are important like
the FDIC Social Security and the idea of
an interventionist government in the
first place but from the 1920s to the
1940s there's not a gigantic revolution
and American democracy capitalism or
social structure things continue the way
that they were and that's why the New
Deal is essentially conservative okay
well I hope this example helped you with
a long essay portion of the AP u.s.
History exam and good luck